[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
jesus
kidding
okay thank you thank you please
getting so popular in my old age thank
you very much
that makes me feel very good because you
know this is our second to last show
next week is the finale
of our season so you're here yeah i know
where does the time go i'm already
watching all the christmas movies on the
hallmark channel
is that believable okay
i got a question for the people over
there at the hallmark channel uh exactly
where is this white rural american town
where no one wears a trump hat
christmas miracle the miracles are not
storming the capitol
oh we got breaking news today we got
adam schiff the perfect guy to talk
about it steve madden was indicted
and uh oh yes all coming to a head
there's a new interview with trump did
you see this
where trump is asked if he thought it
was wrong for the crowd that day on
january 6 to be chanting hang mike pence
and trump says it's common sense
i guess the subtext being have you met
mike pence
i
i am worried
i am worried for this country there's
two racially charged murder trials going
on right now one in georgia one in
wisconsin if there are acquittals there
could be street level unrest adding to
a strain and a system that's already
being plagued by supply chain issues
leading to the question if a store is
completely empty is it still looting
i want to know that
oh yeah this sorcerer are you having
trouble getting [ __ ] you want people are
pissed about this economy i mean it
seems like you have two choices right
out there either what you want isn't
there or if it is you can't afford it
i mean
inflation it's like it's like i'm doing
all my shopping at the airport
oh it's rough
i noticed the women on only fat
are accepting canned goods that seems
oh it's especially bad here in los
angeles a lot of young people cannot
afford their first tent
terrible
but you know
but help is on the way uh or
maybe this will make it worse i don't
know
but uh biden is gonna sign the big 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill on
monday
uh
infrastructure if you're if you're from
hollywood you don't know what that means
uh we're having work done
so
expect to see new signs all around the
city that say your tax dollars at work
next to a big mound of dirt that sits
there for five years that's my
experience
but
uh but here's
this is what's so sad about this country
i mean this is infrastructure the most
boring subject in the world
the 13 out of 213
republicans who voted for it they're
getting death threats
death threats for infrastructure and the
irony of course is that republicans are
always the party of infrastructure
lincoln and grant built the
transcontinental railroad eisenhower the
interstate highway system matt gates
transporting girls across state lines
death threats
anyway
and here's a great christmas story
80 percent apparently now of the deer
population has coveted
i i i know and they say it could mutate
and then jump back to humans yes
anything bad could happen
do we have to [ __ ] go nuts about this
story too
yes it's scary everything's scary
unless you're a deer if you're a deer
this is a great story
this is like remember that year we
thinned their herd
you